hey what's up guys how we doing my
babies
it's uh chris d'elia here and this is
episode 7 is a first ever recorded
seventh episode of congratulations the
podcast um and that and and so and so
you guys are you know what we're all
doing it together that's the thing we're
all doing it together this is the first
episode first ever seventh episode and
I'm I'm amazed we made it this far I'm
really happy that you guys are with me
and you came with me on this journey and
you know because that's what life's
about the journey right you hear people
say that all the time and you know that
that's true because they say it what's
that nothing sounds better than opening
up a coffee like that it's not soda
sounds like my pee soda but it's not
soda it's coffee
it's the caveman nitro coffee I was just
talking my producer about how I think
it's the best a coffee there is but I'm
not being paid to say that I just like I
like the coffee and I liked eight who
made it um I got in an argument with my
dad and my brother last night and here's
the deal man um it was a lot of times in
my family we get in these silly
arguments they're not not shitty we're
making fun of each other but were you're
yelling at each other we're like [ __ ]
you that's not how it is you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and we're laughing and then we [ __ ]
slam one of my I slam my dad my dad
slams me my my my brother slams me I
slam my brother somebody slams my mom
and my mom says how come everybody
always makes fun of me even though
that's not true but that's what my mom
says cuz that's what mom said cuz
females are sensitive sometimes okay
that's it hey guys didn't say men aren't
sensitive just said females are
sensitive sometimes so don't write me
about that okay it's not sexist it's
like it's like saying it's like saying
even though even though like you this
sounds racist it's not racist like man
some Koreans are [ __ ] dumb right it's
not racist even though it is kinda it's
not you know by the way that's not my
tea but some white people are dumb too
some black people are dumb lots of
people are dumb but if you say hey some
Koreans are dumb it sounds [ __ ] super
race it's um I was saying we were
talking about biggest pet peeves and I
and you know my brother was like said
something that like really mattered like
all yeah when people lie or something I
don't know what the [ __ ] it was what he
said but I said Oh am i I know mine a
hundred percent I know my biggest pet
peeve of all time okay uh well not of
all time but of now of the moment you
know pet peeves change right my biggest
pet peeve used to be when you're driving
and you're driving down the street and
somebody's coming down to sit the other
way and you're trying to go left and
you've got your blinker on and the
person's coming up and you see him
coming up but you're gonna let him pass
so you can wait for him to pass and then
take a left but he doesn't pass he takes
his right which is the left you were
going to go into and didn't use his
blinker so you were just waiting there
for a [ __ ] [ __ ] when you could
have went before him you're going to
have to play that part back it makes
sense I said it right but I know you're
confused but this is the this is this
life this drives me nuts though is when
somebody goes to hand you something and
you have something in your hand like
your phone usually it's your phone and
you're texting or whatever and someone
goes here you go and you've got to then
take what the person is handing to you
stop what you're doing and then [ __ ]
figure it out I put it down and I'll
grab it when I want it and my dad says
what do you [ __ ] mean where was that
what is when does that even happen how
does it happen so much that it's you're
peppy that it's even one of your pet
peeves and I said it happens [ __ ] all
the time when you're paying for
something you've got your phone in your
hand or your coffee in your hand you're
buying and then somebody gives you you
give them the credit card and they hand
it back to you with the signing thing
and they're like here you go just sign
that and you get
owning your coffee and I always look at
them and I say oh okay and I put my [ __ ]
on the bucking counter and then I grab
the [ __ ] signing thing and then I do
it and I give it back to them and then I
got a [ __ ] grab up my [ __ ] again
if you put the [ __ ] receipt on the
table I can grab it when the [ __ ] I want
to grab it dude that's actually Rudy's
[ __ ] handing somebody something I think
it's rude as [ __ ] it's so rude handing
something and my dad said it's not rude
and my uncle is like no it's probably a
they do that because that prevents theft
or if somebody comes up they guy they
should hand you your credit card because
then someone could rub it look dude if
somebody puts their [ __ ] credit card
down in front of you and then someone
else steals it from you and it's in
front of you on the table your SLO is
[ __ ] you're slow you tortoise you
deserve to have your credit card taken
from you if you tortoise cuz tortoises
shouldn't have credit cards because
tortoises don't pay for [ __ ] okay so
your tortoise basically if someone puts
something I'm fronting the table and
that's yours and you want to go grab a
bubble free grab it someone grab that
before you that's a hyena your tortoise
and now you're in the animal kingdom you
got a bunch of other things to worry
about
you got a hardshell nobody's going to
eat you but you still got to watch out
because you know certain bears and [ __ ]
could crack your shell and then eat you
cuz you tortoise dude so put something
down on the [ __ ] table and don't hand
me something I watched Iron Man the
movie Iron Man and uh you know Robert
Downey jr. is in it and he's does the
thing he says don't hand me things I
don't like when people hand it to me put
it down and I was like dude that's it
how come [ __ ] Tony Stark knows that
[ __ ] but the barista at the [ __ ] primo
cafe doesn't know it because he thinks
some tortoise not tortoise and that
that's my biggest pet peeve at the
moment it really drives me nuts
it drives me nuts it drives me not to
try as Maina to drive me nuts so you
know but there's lots of it you know pet
peeves and and and [ __ ] it's you know
the it's too it's too annoying to always
talk about pet peeves and [ __ ] we had a
big conversation about it it was a good
dinner but also like um I don't know
also you got to just relax and just let
[ __ ] happen and not get angry I told you
been trying to deal with that [ __ ]
and not be angry I've been trying to
[ __ ] deal with the positive things in
life and just understand why you know
just not even try to understand why the
[ __ ] goes down and to just like let it
happen and be more Zen or whatever the
[ __ ] about it my buddy got me a book on
Zen and he was like hey I sort of got to
solve the book it was 15 years ago
it's right there I'm looking at it
actually and he said hey man I was 21 or
way I was probably 21 22 he said I'm
gonna put this book on your bookshelf
and I know you're not gonna read it but
one day maybe you will read it and when
you read it it's gonna change your life
and just know that when you read it it's
gonna change your life and he was my
best friend at the time and he still is
okay no offense my producers one of my
best friends too and he's also there
tied but but uh I didn't read it yet and
maybe I will read it and when I do and
the only reason why I kept it is because
he's my best friend if he was someone
else I would have [ __ ] taken the book
and use it to wipe my ass when I took
shits um but I respect what he says so
I've been trying to think of the
positive things like that's what you
should do by the way if something
happens and it's a pet peeve and it
bothers you then what you should do is
think of a [ __ ] song like here's the
thing that I keep checking because he's
got a [ __ ] I want to know this is one
of the things that I think about so much
and it's a positive thing but [ __ ]
samuel l.jackson follows me on Twitter
okay
that's so [ __ ] weird to me
he follows like 800 people which is not
that many I mean it's a lot of people if
you put them all in a room but you know
over the years of Twitter you follow
people that's amazing I love Sam Jackson
I have I have no [ __ ] idea why he
would follow me on Twitter dude he
followed me and I like sat down it was
like [ __ ] month years ago and I keep
checking and I checked yesterday I was
gonna [ __ ] Sam Jackson still follows
me on Twitter and he does of all the
dumb [ __ ] I tweet sometimes I put people
on their ass I'm just like [ __ ] you you
piece of [ __ ] to think of Sam Jackson
looking at that and being like
[ __ ] I feel like it was a
mistake and he just bumped the follow
button because somebody retweeted me or
some [ __ ]
maybe [ __ ] uh Taylor Kitsch or
something retweeted me by mistake and
because he was in a movie with him
[ __ ] Sam Jackson was just like if I
hit the follow button now he follows me
and he has to see all my dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
like talking [ __ ] to Kim Kardashian and
he says like who's this [ __ ] I
don't know but that's so weird to think
that to think that [ __ ] samuel
l.jackson dude they make movies and then
they go like okay so but how do we get
Sam Jackson in it though like what was
the one Tarzan Tarzan was the same movie
if Sam Jackson wasn't in it they'll just
be like yeah but Sam Jackson put Sam
Jackson in it they have like a meeting
with the [ __ ] production with the
companies with these big [ __ ] like
huge movie production companies and
they'll be like great great got one note
Sam Jackson and they're like oh um what
do you mean like well we got to get Sam
Jackson it so just right apart for him
and I'm like well it doesn't really they
we don't give a [ __ ] we got to put them
in we gotta pay him twenty million
dollars because if we do that then the
movie will be a hit because everybody
watches Sam Jackson movies hi Sam
Jackson is worth [ __ ] 75 billion
dollars dude and nobody would not go see
a movie that Sam Jackson was in he's the
most watchable [ __ ] dopest dude
also he's been 55 for 75 years how's
that happen
swear to God look at him in [ __ ] pulp
fiction same age same ages now does he
own a time machine
oh I get it Sam Jackson owns a time
machine and just keeps going back and
getting himself and bringing him back to
the future can you hear that can you
hear my dogs in the background I wonder
they're barking in the background I want
to know actually people ask me to talk
about my dogs in my podcast I do like to
keep my personal life out of this [ __ ]
but you know what [ __ ] it dude I have
two dogs and they're cute as [ __ ] and
they're your keys and their names are
Sam and butters and people want to know
why I named one regular name and one
acute name because I wanted to because
that's how I wanted to do it I wanted to
do cute one and I thought was even cuter
if the cute one was the cute name and
then the [ __ ] regular one the other
one was a regular human named Sam and
butters and butters is the [ __ ] fat
one of course dude I feel like he willed
himself to do that because his name was
butters it's like how to pot kept
rapping about death and then got shot
that's what happened I named butters
butters and he was like all right gonna
be fat gotta be a fat so my name is
butters that he's been limping it's so
sad
he's been limping it's so [ __ ] sad
when your dog like starts to limp he
just runs around and [ __ ] he's pees
holding one foot up like there's like oh
it's sad but maybe I'm a sociopath cuz
like I don't really care like I'm like
it'll be fine
but then it's been like a day and a half
should I take him in I'm not gonna take
him in I got tough love for my dogs dude
plus he's fat as [ __ ] dude lose weight I
put the [ __ ] waters in hard to get
places so he at least has to go get it
and [ __ ] shed some fat he turns
around and he literally looks pregnant
it's only his belly - he's like a
[ __ ] old man or like osteoporosis
just set him and he turns around so slow
it's so funny he turned it on so
slow like it's say insecure like he
turns on so slow and he like side looks
at me like yeah you're gonna pay if you
want to pet me it's fine like just
[ __ ] man up dude because Sam will
just run up on my chest and put his face
in my mouth and my yorkese breaths are
[ __ ] terrible by the way
oh dude you've been eating eggs and and
your own [ __ ] for four days oh cool
oh hey dogs you've been eating eggs and
your own [ __ ] all day and bad old
lettuce and tuna oh I don't know dude I
don't know why I don't know what the
[ __ ] dude I used to think about how dogs
like like the when dogs see like a plant
or something and is blown in the wind
they'd be like oh [ __ ] a plant but they
don't think oh [ __ ] a plant that's
[ __ ] that's crazy they don't think in
English dude when you realize that I
sound so high but when you realize that
you look at the plant it's like a dog
look just looks at the plant and it's
not even thinking anything it's just
going ah it's just going it's just like
it's just looking at it dude right
that's crazy
so I've been in LA now for about a week
and a half because I wasn't on the road
this past week I did some shows at The
Comedy Store I did some shows at the
Laugh Factory and they were really
[ __ ] fun and I've been hanging out
chilling you know I do I get coffee I've
been hanging out at the cafe's and [ __ ]
all up and down Sunset Boulevard and I I
don't know if it's summer or what the
[ __ ] is going on I swear in LA and I
don't know I know this is that every
place has plastic surgery but dude the
amount of women I see with [ __ ] fake
lips is unbelievable it's unbelievable
they all look like Simpsons dude they it
fake lips don't look good
they don't look good and you know
alright yeah you can do what you want
and you can [ __ ] you're not doing it
to get a man I get it uh but it looks
awful it and okay yeah maybe nine out of
ten maybe maybe occasionally there's one
that looks fine but dude what I cannot
believe how many [ __ ] come to LA dude
and just sit down and look at the people
that walk by you got homeless women with
with fat with fake lips every by the way
also I've been seeing a lot of homeless
dudes with cell phones what's the deal
man but what the [ __ ] is the fake lip
thing man what it doesn't look it looks
like you put [ __ ] paper mache in the
in the in the under your mouth and and
then you you walk it looks like someone
literally fought you and then you go
walk around with your purse it's so bad
I mean they - just don't get worked on I
feel like don't get any work done
for me I paint my opinion is the only
work that I think that like look
okay our fake boobs and the reason why
is because usually they're in the shirt
and you can't tell if they're fake or
not but if you're going to do something
your face that's insane
do you see that guy stitches got his
[ __ ] son tattooed on his cheek his
baby boy tattooed on his cheek he's a
rapper and guess what
that's all he's ever going to be now you
can't get a tattoo on your face first of
all he's got stitches tattooed on his
mouth that's very stupid yo you know why
that's stupid because just because how
about dude you know like people are like
well it's an opinion yeah but not that
one you get stitches
tattooed on your mouth that's dumb and
that's a fact and you have your son also
that's like saying I oh I'm going to
shut the [ __ ] up while you look at my
son's face on my face dude
hey how about rappers always like yeah
I'm getting [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yo [ __ ]
this guy is not doing that
who wants to [ __ ] a guy with a baby on
his face
what hey what's the most dry the [ __ ]
thing up hmm [ __ ] and then looking in
a baby's eyes dude that's gross that's
so gross I'd rather have sex and then
smell [ __ ] the whole time dude what
the [ __ ] talk about taking you out of it
it's on his cheek it's under his eye so
even if you're trying to like make eye
contact with them you're looking at it's
[ __ ] you're looking at his son also
it's not your
son also it's not your son also dude is
this real I'm looking at a picture of
this guy he's got a teddy bear tattooed
on his forehead which offsets the stitch
as I guess and the ak-47 on his jaw line
and then Tupac next to the teddy bear
holy [ __ ] christ
then more stitches above his other eye
and then above his right eye
he's got the word cocaine above his
[ __ ] hey dude I got a question and
this is just only because I'm not sure
about the answer I'm not sure about the
answer of this question can't be uh I
can't be on a % sure about this but did
this guy have an awful childhood yo dude
this guy's parents treat him well got
this guy he's also I also I heard a song
and it [ __ ] goes hard as [ __ ] like
one of his I heard one of his songs and
I was like dude this is [ __ ] it's
actually for what it is like I know it's
like a lot of people do stupid it sounds
dumb because it's just about it's not
about elevated themes exactly but dude
it [ __ ] goes hard it's good guy
commit you know those there's an eat the
equinox [ __ ] the gym remember the
tagline is or the slogan is commit to
something hey this guy [ __ ] is the
Equinox hero let me get all the tattoos
he walked in the tattoo place and he was
he go like this Davis
oh hi sir and he goes like this all of
them names like oh we only have [ __ ]
these left teddy bear Tupac stitches
ak-47 and the word cocaine all of them
also can you customize my cheek I have a
picture of my son dude
also what if he has another son and then
doesn't get the [ __ ] others
on the other cheek what he has three
what if he has five kids which he will
cuz he's a rapper what if he has five
kids and then and then he has to get all
of his kids all over his faces and
they're all over his faces and and also
to pocket a teddy bear
haha the holy [ __ ] stitches uh that's
incredible man but we know so yeah duck
lips what the [ __ ] dude don't get
[ __ ] fake lips unless you're also
going to get your fingers sewn together
because you're a duck it looks bad girls
guys I want to know if a guy ever did it
right me if you ever knew about a guy
who [ __ ] uh got fake lips Wow
I just gotta be right yeah we'll dummy
definitely no doubt you kidding me a
hundred percent you know how I know that
because a guy got cocaine tattooed on
his [ __ ] eyeball
so a guy definitely got fake lips so so
that's pretty cool man
oh so they're just doing everything I
feel like if there's a God he's just
like alright well that one really got
away with one when I got away from me
yeah I give people free will but a teddy
bear oh alright well okay let's
you know let's make some [ __ ] let's
make a tsunami now since we're on pet
peeves you know another one is [ __ ]
because I fly a lot if you are if you're
on a flight hey I'm going to say this
this is my PSA hey I'm Chris D'Elia if
you're on a flight and it's before you
board sit the [ __ ] down
thanks den Linden Dinda Han
dude if you're on a flight and it's
before it boards sit the [ __ ] down
also it's always people who are in group
six that are just standing in front of
the [ __ ] one lined like little
[ __ ] bottleneck that you can't get in
and they're like senior citizens and
people with no legs first please senior
citizens and people who can't breathe
first please is there anyone that's -
traveling alone crawl to the front
please and then some [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
in in in in in group six with a tank top
on and his [ __ ] family is like
standing in the way and some ninety
[ __ ] a hundred year old man is like
excuse me it takes me an hour to get on
board and then [ __ ] guys like oh are
you are you in first class and he's like
no I just died tomorrow so I get to go
first
like I'm gonna die tomorrow so can I get
on the plane first they asked me to
Jesus Christ could be like okay so we're
boarding only people who are going to
die tomorrow
oh and any one year old traveling alone
ah and a [ __ ] boarding six group
family a fat [ __ ] family with lawn
chairs out in the [ __ ] you need me to
move did you need me to move and the
[ __ ] one-year-old
yeah I'm traveling alone and I got a
[ __ ] on the plane right now I got to
[ __ ] right now
all right family move four inches move
the lawn chairs four inches so a baby
can get on and a guy who dies tomorrow
and someone who can do an army crawl
because they have no legs will move and
and we don't board for another hour and
ten minutes by the way
but I want to I want to make sure to get
on the plane though you're gonna get on
the [ __ ] plane you're gonna get on
the [ __ ] plane we're all going to the
same place what are you worried about
cuz here's what I think you're worried
about not getting to put your bag up on
the bin but guess what you can check it
yeah [ __ ]
you can check it your [ __ ] so let
the [ __ ] four-day-old get on the
plane first with his little knapsack god
damn dude I walked up once and a guy was
in the way I said excuse me and he said
are you in the boarding group that's
boarding and I said yeah that's it what
what do you mean no I'm being a piece of
[ __ ] that's what I should have said now
I'm piece of [ __ ] just gonna stand here
and block it hey sir are you a defensive
end
no well stop blocking this [ __ ] thing
then that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I don't you know flying is just like
annoying his [ __ ] anyway so like just
chill man we're all gonna get in the
plane I don't know I felt like this
podcast would maybe help me come up with
new material and [ __ ] I need new
material I just saw my special and I got
to get out I go on stage and I'm just
doing crowd work I'm [ __ ] with the
audience chopping up some comes up I
forget it all I don't know some of it is
uh that's usually how I write is just to
go on stage and and go up with an idea
you know like I'll go up with an idea
about something like it [ __ ] boarding
groups and then on an airplane and then
I'll [ __ ] play like all this parts
funny there's a funny part here like
I'll get to the and then I'll do it and
then I'll [ __ ] around until I know the
funny part like I'll [ __ ] around like
I'll do I'll just kind of wing it until
I know the part that'll make people
laugh and then I'll just do the peer if
it's failing I'll just do the part that
make people laugh and then I'll get the
laugh and then I'll move on to some
other [ __ ] but I literally I have like
nothing I like elect a foreman it's a
material now and I got to do all these
like like I'm still touring with my hour
when I'm on the road because it didn't
come out yet but when it comes out in
May or June or whatever on Netflix I got
to do new [ __ ] because I don't want
people seeing you know the same [ __ ] um
but uh so I got to do that I'm going to
[ __ ] I got a bunch of dates coming up
though
I can't wait to go to Australia I'm
gonna be in Melbourne and Sydney and I'm
adding a show in Sydney I think I
already did I'm not sure but um yeah and
I'm gonna be going and just [ __ ]
going alone and going and going to see
what's up with all the [ __ ] people in
the Kangaroos out there and [ __ ] how
annoyed must must
Australians be about that by the way
like Americans and [ __ ] being like
asking about kangaroos like how [ __ ]
annoying would that be by the way is
there anything scarier than a kangaroo
oh it jumps on it
tail and kicks you with both feet oh
it's a demon then you know I mean like
that's scarier than a bear dude let's go
that's scarier than a crocodile [ __ ]
[ __ ] off dude
oh it oh it can balance on its tail and
float over to you and kick you with both
feet and kill you that way oh [ __ ] off
dude oh it's a demon then oh you're
talking about a demon like if we came
down to earth and we were aliens and
they were like yeah did this uh this you
move like what's a kangaroo and they're
like that's just this it's this animal
that can plan itself on a long [ __ ]
tough muscular serpent like snake tail
and it can hover from it and balance on
it and then kick you in the [ __ ]
skull with its enormous ski feet and
kill you you would be like oh you said
animal but you mean demon I'm talking
about animals dude that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] that is crazy if I saw a
kangaroo if I ever see a kangaroo I'm
going the other way I don't give a [ __ ]
if I don't guess what I don't give a
[ __ ] if it's near a bunch of uh candy or
whatever the [ __ ] I love coffee if it's
near coffee what's it near coffees and
audiences not going a kangaroo can
balance on its tail dude I mean what is
it a [ __ ] genie dude it can balance on
its tail that's amazing and they can
[ __ ] and they can [ __ ] bow they
can box
oh so it's a person - oh it's a demon
and a person cuz it can box oh it's a
demon fly make Floyd Mayweather
all let's get them off earth then why
are kangaroos on earth they should be on
their own [ __ ] planet called you know
whatever the [ __ ]
King tune to you any like Neptune so
dumb but still uh those are demon
[ __ ] dude so I'm going to
Australia and I can't wait to go and I'm
looking at my ticket counts right now
[ __ ] is selling out so if you're going
to [ __ ] in Raleigh North Carolina that's
going to be gone Oxnard California Tempe
West Palm Beach Atlantic City yeah I
don't I don't know dude I secretly
though I get worried though when I go to
other countries I think that's maybe why
I haven't hit them yet I mean I've got
been other countries but not performing
I just I feel like cuz like what they
have different rules and [ __ ] you know
like you can't kill anybody anywhere I
know that I won't do that but like you
know I mean I'm a good person really I
don't [ __ ] break any laws really but
you know some of these places you'll
[ __ ] you could steal a pack of gum
and they'll cut off your hand you know
not not Australia obviously but I just I
always I'm thinking about that though in
the back of my head where it's like man
I'm in another country and [ __ ] could go
down or I don't even know the areas and
what if like you know don't go to that
area because you know guys have scooters
and they just drive by and pick you up
and then [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you and
then drop you off and you're like oh
what oh that we don't have that in
America okay but that's what we have
over here but I'll just draw a boy I
pick you to scoop you up take you to
their Shack and then [ __ ] you
then they'll get a kangaroo to box yeah
love Damon Damon animal and he'll just
be balanced on his tail and kick you or
the other guy [ __ ] your ass so what
happens so be careful
you know don't go near that area and
then you're like where's the area and
they're like Matt's between the rocks
and the beach like yeah but that doesn't
mean anything to me and they're like see
you later
cheerio that's not Australian but see
you later then he drives away and you're
like I hope my ass doesn't get [ __ ] by
a guy on a scooter but like you can get
it you can go to jail easy way easier if
you're not in [ __ ] America you don't
know what the [ __ ] going on if you're
American dude if I got if I was in jail
bro I was watching one of those lockup
things or whatever the [ __ ] I think part
of it is easier because you could just
literally people just tell you what to
do and you're like alright I'll just
[ __ ] coast throughout the rest of my
life don't have to make any decisions
people tell me to [ __ ] stay in this
box
obviously it's horrible I don't want to
go to jail but in that sense it's got to
be easier you go it's lunch I got to eat
now the fund earning now I'll be hungry
and then you go to bed at like 6:00 p.m.
that's dark out [ __ ] it they want me to
go to bed I'll go to bed then you wake
up at 4:30 a.m. by the way if I go to
jail I was think about this the other
day too
if I go to jail you know how they're
like their guy guys will [ __ ] other guys
because they're not even gay they're
just like it's a power thing number one
and then also they're like I got a
[ __ ] I got a [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] the
rest of my life if I go to jobs singing
how long would it take me to start
[ __ ] guys cuz there's no way I
wouldn't there's no [ __ ] way there's
no way if I was in jail for the rest of
my life everybody's getting [ __ ] I'll
die I'll die trying that's how that it's
like [ __ ] the 50 cent song except
it's not get rich or die trying' it's
get but Hulland die tryin get but holla
or die trying
kill me bro you're getting your ass
[ __ ] that's it that's it and you know
how long you know how long you know how
long people probably crack like after
years alright I guess I'm gonna [ __ ]
this guy dude at least he look he's cute
I'm not gay but at least like he's cute
or something I'll think about women you
know how long it would take me eight
days bro dude [ __ ] this year crack [ __ ]
over maybe a week and I'm if I know I'm
in there for life everybody's getting
[ __ ] the second week that's how it's
gonna be and I'm a dude [ __ ] it all
right blogs about I'm not trying to hide
I don't give a [ __ ] dude I'm [ __ ] you
know whatever I people be scared to me I
think because I'm just could they call
me the [ __ ] yeah how long did it take
him [ __ ] eight days
he started [ __ ] everybody he'd even
start slow he was like he walked into
the commissary and tried to [ __ ] this
guy immediately but the guy beat the
[ __ ] out of him and and and then he was
in the hole for a while but then he and
then the guard let him out he tried to
[ __ ] the guard and he just won't stop
[ __ ] he won't stop [ __ ] no matter
what he does he won't stop [ __ ] he
doesn't even get boners sometimes he
just tries to stuff his dick in in the
[ __ ] buttholes [ __ ] really yeah [ __ ]
when you start doing that eight days
after he got in what yep he's in here
for life
it wouldn't even be how long is he in
here for uh [ __ ] two years he got the
biz on some internet [ __ ] he tried to
rob [ __ ] sixty dollars from someone's
bank account by logging into their walls
Fargo oh really and he got a year yeah
and he [ __ ] a bunch of guys eight days
in he's not going out a year without
without that [ __ ] he [ __ ] a TV he
[ __ ] three guys a day he pay that's how
he passes the time he [ __ ] a guard he
[ __ ] a guard did the other guards
tried to stop him but he had too tight
of a grip bro
I guess this is awful to talk about but
like we know [ __ ] jails awful also
it's a comedy podcast you know and then
I get out of prison and that's the
[ __ ] book that would come out it
would be called everybody's getting
[ __ ] and on the inside flap it would
be a really nice black and white picture
of me sitting in a wicker chair
like with the glasses on even though he
wore glasses the guy's vision may be got
padding in in in prison chapter 1
everybody and then it starts eight days
in I had enough Rick was about to get
[ __ ] that's the first sentence and you
read that and you buy the book because
that's the most amazing start of to any
book everybody's getting [ __ ] chapter
one everybody uh beginning of the
beginning of the chapter
I've had enough it's been eight days
Rick was looking good and I'm by the way
I'm [ __ ] the big guys I'm not going
after that that easy [ __ ] mentally I
feel like it would [ __ ] serve me
better I mean what the [ __ ] you know I
don't know I guess I'm never running for
president um that's what I always think
about when I'm talking about when I do
this kind of [ __ ]
I guess I'm never running for president
dude by the way you know how people are
like that actually times are changing
though because I always feel like you
are you already did the thing that you
that would bury you politically like
just whoever you are we've already done
the thing that would bury us politically
think about yourself and think about the
[ __ ] that you've done you've done the
thing that would bury you politically
but that all change with Donald Trump he
was talking about grabbing [ __ ] on a
bus with Billy Bush dude nobody's done
anything worse than that talking about
grabbing [ __ ] on a bus with Billy
Bush oh that's the worst thing you could
kill five people and still go for and
still become president before you could
talk about grabbing [ __ ] in a bus
with Billy Bush even Jesus Christ is
like oh hell for that guy I mean that's
like come on
and he's president I'm not
saying where I go politically but that's
crazy that he became president and he
dead didn't bury him so now we can do
whatever we want but before Trump dude
we already did the thing that buried us
politically no doubt and mine was just
talking about how everyone was getting
[ __ ] in prison after eight days I was
in there for a misdemeanor oh [ __ ]
that's what I was doing I would [ __ ] the
guy and I would be thinking oh it's
really too bad for this guy I stole $60
half of out of a Wells Fargo account
some dude who works at IKEA I don't know
man maybe I would just find the guys who
were down work out I would work out huh
I mean I guess I would worry if I was in
jail I would work out so hard as hard as
possible I guess I'd read so many books
and [ __ ] guys all the time those would
be my three hobbies and I keep Thai I
wouldn't keep to myself dude I would try
to be the I would try to be the leader
of everybody by like busting balls and
[ __ ] and I'm bill big yeah but don't
bust his balls too hard he'll [ __ ] you
and then some of the gay guys would be
like so uh you know um yeah I would try
to do I would try to be a leader in I
was talking about who a leader is I was
all I was driving with my buddy and he
was like he's he's like you're now you
know he was telling me how he thought I
was an alpha male or whatever which is
like okay you know fine and but he was
telling me that because I feel like he
wanted to say he wanted me to tell him
that he was an alpha male and I don't
think he is and now and he first of all
he was in my passenger seat you know and
he was like uh you know I I'm an alpha
male though and I was like oh really and
he was like of course I was like first
of all alpha males don't tell people
that they're alpha males because just
you're gonna figure it out on your own
but I was I got really I guess I don't
well I usually come and hang out with
you and your friends but if you saw me
like in my element you would you would
understand that I'm the alpha male and
I'm like yeah all right dude like what
do you mean what's your element and he
was like well if we were in the jungle
you would be like asking me what to do
and there's a no way in hell I would be
doing that but I was just like a really
cool man he was like yeah yeah
and I I know and and he was trying to
convince me he was an alpha male and I
was like I don't know if you are an
alpha male though and he was like what
what what makes you say that I was like
take you know I thought of Joe Rogan
because Joe Rogan is Joe Rogan is just
the most undoubted undoubtedly alpha
male that I know and I was like just
take him plug him into any situation any
situation put him a construction workers
put up with lawyers put him with
comedians put him with [ __ ] smart
people put him a dumb people put him
with a bunch of [ __ ] koalas all those
koalas would be like well let me do now
gel that's just an alpha male and I was
like you're not that you plop you enough
but in a room full of [ __ ] lawyers
you're the weirdo dude you're the weirdo
you put [ __ ] you know I don't know
what and I don't know I guess there's
degrees cuz like my opener is I think a
version of an alpha male but he's not he
works for me so it's like hard to say
he's not the alpha male when we're
around right but then you get guys who
are like really [ __ ] successful at
what they do like you know I don't know
in my profession it's [ __ ] Chris Rock
Dave and [ __ ] you know a bluey ck and
you know in my head those guys are all
alpha males but I don't know if they are
I don't you know some of those guys are
know personally but some of them I don't
so I don't know
you know because also you can be a
comedian and be real
but still be a [ __ ] draw you know
because it's beta dammit to be a [ __ ]
and that's also funny you know you're up
there and you're like I can't get a girl
and people argue that's a lose right um
but I don't know dude he was trying to
convince me he was now female and you
know you know if you have to convince
somebody you're an alpha male you are a
beta male you're a [ __ ] Omega male or
whatever the [ __ ] is the last one
Zeta male Catherine zeta-jones male um
yeah
in hilarious probably that he was in my
passenger seat telling me this while we
were driving oh cool oh really you're an
alpha male well we're gonna go where the
[ __ ] I'm telling us or I guess I don't
know it's pretty alpha to be driven
around maybe maybe that's how he was
thinking but this guy also says [ __ ]
like what gene should I get high you're
not an alpha male what gene sheet should
you get the ones you like guy but what
ones are cool I was sad where do you
shop sad we're gonna get to drink sad
who do you want to sit sad what should I
say to this girl
sad should I text her sad should I wait
another sad going on vacation with my
mom sad for 10 days though and she's my
best sad these are all things that he
said you know I don't know man love the
guy love them bust his balls forever and
one time he called me bothersome and I
[ __ ] almost pissed myself laughing to
call another male bothersome oh [ __ ] I
almost pissed myself laughing and he
runs with it now it's I want to punch
him in the face because of it now he's
like what gives you know you're
bothersome like I said it that one time
want to punch him it was hilarious that
made me laugh so hard we were at the
diner any call me bothersome and I
[ __ ] fell out I had to sit I had to
[ __ ] sit down and I was already
sitting down it was awesome
sometimes I go to that this diner in LA
and it's got so many hipsters man but I
love the food and it's got some vegan
[ __ ] so hipsters go so many hats hat
central dude beards and hats central
they got cows on the wall swingers it's
called it's really good
but boy do I want to knock the [ __ ] out
everybody else that goes in there um
that's it alright will winding down dude
it's been 47 minutes I don't know how
long you want to [ __ ] take me to
subscribe to my oh here's what I wanted
to say go to my newsletter you scoops
you could subscribe to my [ __ ] on a
Chris D'Elia calm dude and it's easy to
unsubscribe to dude I was I was a member
of 24 Hour Fitness in in Hollywood in
like the ArcLight
when I lived over there dude I they were
safe siphoning money from my account
after I [ __ ]
ended the thing it took me four months
do they stole money for me for four
[ __ ] months I had to call him every
month
hey man I'm still getting the bill all
we have to come in and and and we don't
take a sign we don't take cancellations
over the phone oh well assure you sure
as [ __ ] took it when I [ __ ] signed up
you [ __ ] demon dude and then I had to
call corporate no I'm calling you bro I
signed up with you sign me out and stop
stealing my [ __ ] money dude
so annoying that's my money that I work
for and you're taking it monthly why is
it so hard to unsubscribe from [ __ ]
people are [ __ ] thieves oh thanks for
sight thanks for doing the one-click
sign up if you want to sign out here's
what you got to do first of all wish you
have to wish for three hours then at the
end of that call us we'll give you
another number to call you call them and
they'll give you an email to email the
email come back they'll give you a
number and then you call that number and
speak to someone in North Korea who only
speaks Korean but we'll get you a
translators address that you have to go
to and you got to get him on the phone
with you on speaker so he can tell you
what the Korean guys saying and then
you've got to do it all on one leg while
he's trying to [ __ ] gouge your
eyeballs out and it might work go [ __ ]
yourself
dude let me hey you know what it should
take hey I don't want to be a member
anymore
okay bye but it's not you're trying to
steal [ __ ] money because II your
piece is [ __ ] that's why did you know
why cuz II your piece has shared um yeah
dude
take some questions from the
congratulations pothead hashtag here's
one didn't know what it meant from
Calvin El Faro at Calvin El Faro very
good name good job on getting your name
Chris my legal name is Saddam whoops
take it back why'd you make it Calvin El
Faro bye next question not doing it
don't have [ __ ] three names dude
you're just one guy that's what that
[ __ ] with [ __ ] Chief Keef draws
drives me nuts you don't really get to
choose your name
the people who [ __ ] you came out of
their balls and [ __ ] choose your name
that's it if you don't like the name
time your name is Tom you got a [ __ ]
live Tom til you die from Brett Dahlberg
at Bret drums okay maybe he likes the
drums that's fine thinking about adding
a 69 or 420 to my Twitter handle so
Krista Lea can tell me to change it
that's good yeah I would [ __ ] you I
would boy would I
boy would I you cute you're trying to be
cute with your [ __ ] handle bye what's
your take on young this is from young
jazzy Jas
Jas e J's young Jace young Jace I guess
what's your take on young thug's album
Jeffrey and his tracklist let me read
the tracklist first of all this guy's
dressed in a dress
young thug Wow raps changed first song
called
Wyclef John alright well so far this is
the most confusing goddamn thing of all
time this guy's name is young thug his
album's name is Jeffrey and his first
tract his name Wyclef Jean that's a
different person
his second track alright well oh I see
where this is going
his second track is named Floyd
Mayweather his third one is Swizz Beatz
so the first three tracks are three
different guys that exists then it's
future swag which I don't know if that's
a person or not then its rear who's
Rihanna which is another person then
it's go up which means money then it's
Haram Bay which is the [ __ ] eight
that got killed then it's we be another
person then it's Kanye West another
person and then the last bonus track is
pick up the phone and that's probably a
bonus track
because he couldn't think of a name to
call it and it's just pick up the phone
he's ideal but I like to pick up the
phone song and then some other dude was
like well why don't you just have it a
bonus track he was like yeah good idea
god damn what are these songs about I
you know what these songs are probably
all about [ __ ] [ __ ] and making
money hey let's call it [ __ ] Flyway
Mather he does that too let's call it
flight clubs John he maybe does that too
Kanye West
Harambee doesn't do that and whatever I
said flow away meth or something
Mayweather I mean like I'm [ __ ]
Foghorn Leghorn I'll say I'll say lol
Floyd Mayweather oh well away a fly
McCoy way way method I don't know what
my post mates is almost here so i'ma go
but you guys [ __ ] we did it man 53
minutes we're getting up there dude
listen it really helps if your rate and
review us it really helps if you tell
your friends it really helps if you you
share it you check us out on YouTube you
check the website congratulations pop
pod comm right that what it is yeah and
it helps if you share it on Instagram
and Twitter and you write me with the
congratulations pod hashtag thank you
for listening I got some dates coming up
you know where they are
I just [ __ ] set them but I'll go
through them quick Raleigh Greensboro
North Carolina Raleigh Greensboro North
Carolina Virginia Beach s hould Oh
Oxnard California Melbourne Sydney
that's in Australia Tempe Arizona
Phoenix Arizona West Palm Beach Florida
Baltimore Maryland Atlantic City New
Jersey and Huntington New York that sold
out but we're adding another show so and
then when I'm in town in LA always check
the Comedy Store web sites or the Laugh
Factory website or The Improv website
I'm all around and and I perform there
all the time people always say when you
come into LA I live in LA [ __ ]
I'll live in LA
so thanks for thanks for doing it and
thanks for listening you guys have a
good day my babies